hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
[Applause]
um
monday uh may 30th 2022
[Music]
sorry man i just had a double espresso
that's my new [ __ ] man it's my new [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] legal cocaine dude leave it
alone
i don't have a problem
um oh double shot of espresso on
memorial day everybody come on sing it
with me happy memorial day to you
happy memorial day to you
cause you didn't take the time to thank
the troops
you just went to a barbecue
and you ate a bunch of [ __ ]
and you got some man tits
and you felt a tightness in your chest
so you made yourself puke in the shrubs
and your buddy's wife saw it
all right sorry
that's always the worst
you know we do something dumb and your
buddy's wife sees it you're like oh god
do i wait for her version and then i
tell my version or do i tell my version
first
you know you gotta wait
you gotta wait you know what's annoying
i was just walking down the street
and i was minding my own business you
know what it really annoys me i don't
like um
when a woman dresses seductively but
isn't confident
is there anything worse than that
because then you're walking past them
and they have this uncomfortable look on
their face and it [ __ ] makes you feel
like a creep and it's like i didn't tell
you to dress like that and i wasn't even
looking at you stop [ __ ] making that
face like i'm leering at you
i'm just gonna say hello you're the one
who wore a [ __ ] half shirt
it's [ __ ] breezy out you know put a
whole shirt on
put a whole shirt on until you can walk
down the street you gotta be like
beyonce
if you're gonna dress like that you
gotta [ __ ] be walking down the street
like you can never get this right and
then it makes all the guys be like yes
yes queen
yes
whatever the [ __ ] they do with those
concerts
um no i don't want to make fun of
beyonce jesus christ then i'll have all
those [ __ ]
pudgy people coming after me
[Laughter]
sorry it's the espresso man i like it
you know i sit there i feel like uh just
we uh
just america
uh
uh
go [ __ ] yourself um
i'm getting back into my french man i'm
back up i'm up to [ __ ]
number 27
on pimsleur you got to do pimsleur this
is i'm this is not even i'm not even
getting paid to say this [ __ ] you got to
do pimsleur that's that's where it's at
i mean part of this might be the coffee
talking but yeah i'm a little [ __ ]
ramped up here i'm not going to lie to
you you know i'm psyched about him off
the road for two weeks
right
i'm off the road again
boom boom old bald billy's off the road
again
he can hang out with his two little
friends
that's all i did this morning
so i just played with my kids
it's hilarious
both of them hilarious we were playing
uh shoots and ladders which i realize
that's what i'm gonna do now when i want
to curse i'll be like ah shoots and
ladders
that works right so you kind of feel
like you're saying [ __ ] but not really
um
and before all the australians write in
i i okay i get it ladders and snakes is
what you called it we said shoots you
know what i mean they're like they think
it's because we can't handle snakes
or something like that that's not the
reason why you guys called it snakes and
ladders because you have all of those
[ __ ] ridiculously poisonous snakes
out there i mean we got rattlesnakes
here but you never see them
you know people in australia go out to
get their mail and they just never come
back
they either get bit by a snake or some
joey comes over and [ __ ]
kicks the [ __ ] memory out of their
head
um
and they're not koala bears they're kind
of [ __ ] too you know they're like
koala bears they're like star wars fans
like nerds you know what i mean where
they're just sort of [ __ ] laid back
and you think that they're nice because
they're quiet and then you know
then you give them a hug and they pee on
your leg i don't know i i i gotta i
gotta work on that reference
okay
i wanna thank everybody that came out to
las
vegas las vegas
this weekend at the cosmopolitan i had
such a great time there
uh i was working with todd rex
and mark simmons
um
mark went up the second night you got to
see that guy man [ __ ] hilarious todd
rex
did two completely different sets was
[ __ ] hilarious
i love that guy man t-rex t-rex is what
he goes by and uh just one of the
silliest funniest [ __ ] dudes
on stage and off
to hang out with we had a blast
and um
we were just doing the thing about is
when i hang out with todd all we do is
archie
bunker and ah patty cake patty cake
vegas man yeah just doing all this
stupid [ __ ] that only makes sense to us
and it usually takes me like three days
to shake it off like i came home you
know i see my wife i'm like oh jeez
edith you ding bad there
she's just like
you were hanging out with todd this
weekend weren't you i was like yeah
i'm sorry um
but i actually came home you know and uh
my daughter you know was like daddy and
i started speaking french to her and she
was speaking it back to me it's gonna be
sick because i'm gonna learn it as she
learns it and then as we get older we're
gonna get to talk [ __ ] about people that
we're looking at in french and it's
gonna be my uh gonna be another thing
another daddy-daughter date
you know let's go out in public and
trash people and they don't know what
we're talking about
um
another great reason to learn another
language it brings you closer to your
kids
right
um
anyway so we were out in vegas
and uh
i do what i usually do after after the
first night the next morning i go i wake
up and i go for a little stroll there
um i went over to the mgm which i hadn't
been to in years and i always loved that
one i'm a sucker for green
green car i just love a [ __ ] green
car that [ __ ] british racing green i
just think it's beautiful kelly green
fender guitar that surfer green all of
that [ __ ] i just i like it
so i was always drawn to going over
there and um i went over to the sports
book my favorite thing in the [ __ ]
world to do have a little action on the
game
and uh smoking a [ __ ] little cigar
there
watching some innings or some quarters
whatever the [ __ ] it is but uh they
don't let you smoke over there so i was
a little disappointed with that
but uh whatever we had a nice little
walk came back
i did uh
i did my show turned out there was a
buddy of mine that was doing a show
bigger show than me the next day he
ended up staying
on my floor right before i left so i
went down
you know hung out with him for a cup of
coffee which was great
um
it's a good time it's a good time but i
don't like going out there without you
know my wife or whatever you know
sitting in a [ __ ] room like howard
hughes
watching your nails grow you know
um
anyway
but where i was looking out my window i
could see the tropicana and way back in
the day that's the first place i ever
headlined
before i was ready and i remember i
headlined two nights and i just wasn't
getting them
i've told this story before and i got i
got bumped down i got i got sent down
back to triple a
they flipped the
the feature was really a headliner and
he was experienced and they flipped and
i just it was very humbling but
they were both the host and the guy were
both cool about it or whatever and i
just was like all right
i mean i saw the lady called me up and
she was just like hey bill you know it's
so-and-so from the tropicana
i'm like hey how you doing she goes good
um
how do you think the shows have been
going
that's just like oh no here we go
oh billy backpedal um
anyway but this is what i wanted to talk
about
this isn't the biggest [ __ ] news out
there the biggest news is your boston
celtics
nba action is fantastic are going to the
nba finals finals finals
against the golden state warriors
and i have to tell you something i tried
to watch that game seven i cannot watch
the [ __ ] nba like i don't understand
how sports fans watch the nba and not
realize that this [ __ ] is it's just
assisted you're watching assisted
reality
that's what it is like the level of
power that officials have
i just refuse to believe i'm not saying
that the game is fixed i'm saying that
it is it is controlled
like the level of control that the
referee has it's here's a deal
all right the first quarter belongs to
the players the second quarter if need
be
the officials insert themselves to make
sure that it's only gonna be a five to
seven point game
at by halftime so if somebody comes out
and they're [ __ ] hot and they're up
by 15 17 20 points the nba they can't
have that the casual fans gonna turn the
[ __ ] channel
but fortunately it's basketball
and the referee has the ability to take
players out of the game by calling fouls
on them or
you know just calling fouls on the whole
team and getting them in the penalty
which puts the other team on the [ __ ]
line i swear to god every [ __ ] how
many [ __ ] times can you nba fans
watch a team
have a [ __ ] 20 point lead and just
watch it evaporate in the final [ __ ]
six minutes of a quarter and then cue
the stephen a smith guy at halftime to
inject drama in this what should have
been a drama-less game going like i'll
tell you right now i am really concerned
about the team that was up by 20 is now
only up by six
and you think you're watching the game
then they come out third quarter they
let him play for a half a [ __ ]
quarter and the the [ __ ] job of the
referee is to make sure that it comes
down to the final two [ __ ] minutes
that's what it is it's it's a business
it's a [ __ ] business and i really
believe
that like
it's cast like a show
all right and what they repeat every day
every year is they're trying to get
celtics versus lakers not those teams
but
the lakers through shrewd moves in a
trade and the celtics through the same
thing in the 1980s were basically two
super teams
and they were these two juggernauts that
faced off
year after year and because of that the
nba
with the help not dr j first
then it was burden magic and that just
took it to the stratosphere and they
ended up passing baseball and football
and i believe they became the number one
sport in the 80s and then michael jordan
carried him the rest of the way to 1998
and ever since then
like during that time that became their
[ __ ] business model
so what they do is i just feel like they
try to recreate
the showtime lakers and the 80s celtics
by allowing these pylon teams to happen
so they have these two juggernauts
and then the referee's job is to kind of
you know
not fix the game but massage it enough
that the the the
biggest money-making scheme has the best
chance
of of
getting to the big dance that that's
what i feel because i feel like last
night if miami was on that game and they
went up by 15 or 17 i've
i'm telling you they miami would have
been in the penalty by the second
quarter and then the celtics would be
able to shave it to eight or nine to
keep people hanging in there watching
the game i don't understand
how the [ __ ] you guys can keep
looking at this [ __ ] and not think that
this is what it is
i mean some of those [ __ ] calls
and then the great thing is all you got
to do is just have a [ __ ] called the air
quote makeup call and then that becomes
the
that's that's their alibi it's like the
chris paul move when they didn't let
chris paul
go to the lakers that's their [ __ ]
alibi when i sit there and say like yeah
dude they just allowed these super teams
to happen and every [ __ ]
mouth-breathing [ __ ] always goes well
what about the chris paul train and i
always go give me another one
and they got nothing they got nothing
because they allow it to happen i'm
telling you it's cast like a [ __ ]
show
and uh so when i watch the nba i watch
the first quarter i watch the beginning
of the third quarter to the referees
start imposing their will and then i
come back in the final two minutes
knowing that you know seven out of ten
times it's gonna come down to the wire
because that keeps people watching and
it's a [ __ ] business all right
i don't know i hate to say there's no
santa claus but like i've just seen too
many i remember stern saying you know
what what's what's your uh dream final
and he's like the lakers versus the
lakers and that doesn't mean
he's a laker fan it just meant they got
the best ratings and that makes me the
most money
you know
i remember hearing a particular player
ask them what happened in that series
and he said we didn't fit the nba's
script this year
i remember they had a mobbed up ref
which this was outside the nba
that's another thing too is there's
inherent leaks in the dam over in the
nba i believe because of the level of
power that an nba ref has it was
inevitable that the mob was going to get
in the air of some
referee and the fact that they did the
lee harvey oswalt on him
and they just did the lone gunman magic
bullet [ __ ]
i've said this since this [ __ ] happened
if you were on an officiating crew and
one of the guys on your crew was fixing
games how [ __ ] long would it take you
to figure that out
i'm saying by the second quarter in the
second game
you'd be pulling me aside going bill
what the [ __ ] what you all right dude
you're going through some [ __ ] in your
personal life like what's going on here
um
i don't that's just
that's just my opinion so i'm not saying
that the best teams don't [ __ ] win or
well i'm just saying that i i feel it
feels like a show to me more so than any
other
sport you know where i feel like
you know hockey's a [ __ ] free-for-all
um
yeah i just feel like the rest of them
they you know they the star players get
the calls that's sort of straight across
the board but basketball's the only one
i watch where i'm like
okay they're calling it tight now
they're letting them play
now they're now they're calling it tight
again it's just like they it's
i don't know it i don't know
call me nuts call me a [ __ ] i mean i
remember when i said it was fixed in the
2000s and everybody looked at me like i
was a lunatic but i was also you know
talking about the federal reserve and
all kinds of other [ __ ]
and i remember when that guy got busted
and i went down to the cellar thinking i
was going to be vindicated and everybody
was just well you know it was just one
guy they literally just say
you know
they just say what they heard on tv it
was just like you know they have weapons
of mass destruction and and everybody's
like they have weapons of mass
destruction and then they couldn't find
it and and they were like oh it's a
liberation and then it's a liberation
it was just one guy it was just one guy
[Music]
whatever that's my uh
that's my [ __ ] like i
i was so upset watching that game
yesterday i was just like i'm not
[ __ ] doing this again and i i
literally walked out and i and i went
back in enough to see that time when
that guy on the heat took that off
balance shot and after the ball was
released
like
jayson tatum touched the side of his hit
hip the way you would high-five a baby
and the guy called blew the whistle and
i think he blew the whistle because
tatum was near him and the guy was all
off balance and he was like that [ __ ]
ain't going in and then it [ __ ] went
in he's oh even better and
let's make it closer i think they have
these little [ __ ]
wires on them the referees
and the commissioner when it's getting
too [ __ ] crazy he zaps them you know
like how they train like a sheltered dog
and then their [ __ ] arm goes up
all right i'm getting a little crazy
all right i am getting a little crazy
but i i really do believe
that the nba
is massaged i'm not saying it's fixed
but it's definitely
there's there's
you know the scenario
that they're looking for if it was fixed
though if it really was fixed i don't
think the spurs
win all those championships because they
weren't
what the nba would call
an exciting team for the casual fan i
love the [ __ ] spurs
i love the discipline team like that i
love the [ __ ]
you know a guy turn around jumper off
the glass i love that [ __ ] right
but i just feel like you know and in
defense of the nba i think all sports in
general
out of greed have really
tried to ramp up the offense it's not
necessarily just out of
greed it's also out of the fact that
there's now netflix and the internet and
video games and
all of this
internet porn all of this [ __ ] that
people want cord cutters and all that so
they have to just make
it's got to be like uh
like
i think that chiefs bills game in the
playoffs last year is what the [ __ ]
they're looking for
every game
and i was really astounded by the amount
of people that called themselves
football fans that enjoyed that game i'm
like
oh so you just like to see scoring and
like no like the most the worst [ __ ]
defense you've ever seen in your life so
you're not a fan of the [ __ ]
you know the the steel curtain the doom
state defense the orange crush the soul
patrol the purple people leaders back
when defense defenses don't have [ __ ]
nicknames anymore
then it all became the three-headed
monster the greatest show on turf
the [ __ ] three amigos and all of this
[ __ ] it just became all about offenses
never used to have uh the run and gun
they just slowly they started taking
over
you know i just realized
i should be sitting in a chair right now
with old man slippers on and a blanket
over my legs going like damn let me tell
you how sports used to be
so i'll take that from you guys all
right i am an old man but i'm you know
i'm going to watch the finals or
whatever now here's what i think about
the final
all right i feel like the celtics are
like a mid-season replacement
you know what i mean they have you know
they have a couple of nice ideas out
there
but you know we have our jennifer
anistons and courtney cox you know but
we don't have we don't have a good
villain
you know you got to have the cutie pie
stars but you need a good villain and i
feel like the golden state warriors they
have their jennifer aniston and then
they have they have their bad guys
you know so i think that that's why
they've made it to syndication over the
last like seven years i think that's
that's why the network of nba keeps
greenlighting them
to uh go to the finals where i feel like
the celtics
you know they're like a draft away on
the script
before they feel like they can make some
money off of these guys i don't know
we shall see um
now here's the deal they just let him
play they just let him play and these
[ __ ] refs don't impose their will
that's another thing too like name a
sport any other sport where the
officiating crew literally dictates the
tempo of the game
speeding it up slowing it down and all
of that [ __ ]
um
and look i understand like in hockey
they got to do something to you know if
it's getting too [ __ ] violent they
have to do something
i get that i'm not talking about that
i'm talking about
you know tension and release
you know pulling back on the [ __ ]
reigns to make sure you know
all right bill i think you've made your
point okay all right
whatever
you know blame it blame it on the
espresso
it's just how i feel but here's years
ago if if the celtics and the warriors
just play
i don't think that this is going to be
this is either going to be the warriors
are just going to destroy us
or the celtics are gonna win
and if the celtics win it's going seven
and uh i don't know enough about hoop
admittedly i know enough to know that
something's going on but like
if we can d him up
i think it's gonna take seven games
for us to beat him but they've been
there before
a bunch of times and uh i think they
could easily just steamroll us
but i think if we just get a victory
early
get a little confidence and we drag them
into the deep water i don't think
that they're built to go
seven um
and i can say this
as a 54 year almost 54 year old white
guy who can barely hit a layup that's my
prediction
that's my tale of the tape
as a guy i'll tell you know what's
[ __ ] underrated
going for a stroll
[ __ ] this working out [ __ ]
just taking a walk
just being with yourself
you know
talking to yourself to people in your
life there's nothing better when you're
talking about when you're having an
argument with someone in your life that
isn't there
i mean
you're gonna win
right
just walking down the street you know
and you get so into it you don't notice
people walking by and they're just
staring at you
and you're over there whispering and
another thing i'll tell you what the
[ __ ] else i'm sick of okay and you think
i'm handling taking this [ __ ] you got
another [ __ ] thing coming okay
because
i don't know who the [ __ ] you think i am
okay cause i'm not the one you know you
try to [ __ ] do the white guy head
roll there because you watch reality tv
um
anyway can i can i read some advertising
here for you
uh thank you to all the troops out there
man
uh
doing all whatever it is that they have
you doing right now
i love talking to troops man they're
[ __ ] fun people
you know it's funny like people who
aren't troops when they're on tv the way
they talk to them it's the same way they
talk about firemen you know
these heroes they're out there you know
protecting your lives and all that
and then when i meet firemen i'm just
like all right tell the truth dude when
you're not out there
taking a cat out of a tree you're
smoking cigars and [ __ ] hookers right
yeah
a lot of down time buddy
all right it's movement watches everyone
mv
mt
michael victor michael tango
uh in a tiny apartment in southern
califor california two college dropouts
teamed up to create a watch brand that
broke all the rules
with fair prices
unexpected colors what is that
and clean original designs
you gotta like clean and original
designs a clean design you know what
that means that means clash
you know
not these big stupid watches that people
may look at me i got nothing to say so
maybe i can distract you with my wrist
uh mvmt pronounced movement grew into
one of the fastest growing watch brands
shipping to over 160 country countries
across the globe
now movement has expanded into blue
light glasses [ __ ] i have to get some of
those
i always forget you know i need somebody
else to [ __ ] come on and advertise
about how to help your memory and then i
take that [ __ ] and then i'll remember to
get these blue light glasses
this is why i like them they're sleek
jewelry and more style
essentials that don't break the bank oh
wait no sorry blue light glasses sleek
jewelry and more style essentials that
don't break the bank all designed out of
their california headquarters see that
you see that copy at first they were in
a tiny apartment now they're in
headquarters
you know like the hall of justice
i used to [ __ ] love that man
to this day man like like a lab rat if
they start playing that [ __ ]
horn you know when the super friends
would turn it around
[Music]
i had so much stress and once they
started playing that i'm like oh good
here they come
um anyways all designed out of their
california headquarters and y'all are
now the first to know that movement is
made having a huge
sitewide sale for father's day and y'all
is this the nate barghotzi copy that i
got here
um their prices are slashed up to 40 off
from may 31st to june 17th to make sure
you can get the perfect gift for dad
from classic dress watches to adventure
watches to summer reading boating
sunnies
i'm gonna ask for those blue glasses for
father's day
let's start doing those things this
podcast wearing blue glasses
double shot of espresso
right i'm gonna be like the horus grant
a [ __ ] podcasting uh quality modern
watches for a fair price super duper
durable sunglasses with uv rated
polarized lenses and and uh timeless
styles their premium blue light glasses
will not only look you make you look
great who is that but filter 90 off
uh
i think it's supposed to be 90 of the
most intense blue light rays from your
digital screen so you can scroll
comfortably
it just sounds amazing man i hate when
your [ __ ] eyes get tired from looking
at these screens wouldn't it be great if
somebody created a product that solved
that problem movement is going all out
for father's day there's no better gift
than a classic watch or sunnies
thank you for the dad you gave me this
year
uh all on sale for dad's big day shop up
to 40 off for father's day shop up to 40
off for father's day and save big on the
perfect gift for dad join the movement
by going to
mvmt.com
michael victor michael tango dot com
slash bur b-u-r-r
now and enjoy up to forty percent off uh
once again that's mvmt.com
oh look who it is it's liquid death
um
some of the liquid death people came out
to my show this weekend
uh liquid death the water
is giving me life why do they call it
liquid death because liquid death will
brutally murder your thirst murder and
these aluminum tall boys i got one right
now
you hear it
drinking one right now ice cold it's
[ __ ] delicious it's not another
plastic bottle in the ocean listen to
how good this is
[Music]
yeah
it's [ __ ] delicious let me ask you
this would you ever drink beer out of a
plastic bottle of course you would
because you're an alcoholic
um
but you know you want it in a bottle or
you want it in a [ __ ] can this whole
[ __ ] thing where you just stick them
in plastic bottles and throw it in the
ocean is stupid all right people
wouldn't it be great if somebody put it
in a can not only does it taste better
but it won't [ __ ] be floating in the
ocean for 800 to 1 000 years after
you're dead
well welcome to liquid death
these aluminum tall boys are infinitely
recyclable so they bring they're
bringing death to plastic bottles death
to plastic people think about your kids
man
try to think of something more hardcore
than that spoiler you can't
you can keep thinking but it's not gonna
work out murder your thirst and kill
plastic pollution save the earth look
dope as hell with liquid death it takes
up to a thousand years for a plastic
bottle to decompose
your plastic will outlive you
okay i don't give a [ __ ] how many dick
cheney heart [ __ ]
replacements you get aluminum is
infinitely recyclable and actually
profitable for recycling facilities dude
what if what if modern medicine got so
great that they could [ __ ] rebuild
your insides like aaron kaufman can
right i'm going to put some big brakes
down by his feet you know get him a new
power train all mem and and then when
you survived
is you had to clean up the [ __ ] mess
that you made
help recycle it and you just wander the
earth
and that's who you are now like you like
that would be the zombie that you were
well that would suck right
then you have people breaking off
that's a good beginning of sci-fi we're
gonna keep you alive because you have to
clean up your carbon footprint
so then you're psyched you're still
alive but now you're like jesus christ
why did i buy all of this [ __ ] all right
let me just keep going here aluminum is
infinitely recyclable and actually
profitable for recycling facilities look
cool drinking a crisp tall boy filled
with fresh mountain spring water and
reduce waste it's a win-win-win
situation you'll see these cans popping
up everywhere liquid death is available
at your local whole foods 7-eleven
target
albertsons safeway or amazon but you
know that's not all you can
rock liquid death merch
that crazy logo that you know and love
is now available on sweatshirts hats
even license plate holders and don't you
dare pay for shipping go to liquid
death.com
burr to get free shipping on all water
and merch that's
liquiddeth.com to get free shipping on
all water and merch liquid death murder
your thirst
oh i love when i do that dramatic pause
at the end
reminds me that guy and now you know
the rest of the story
um paul harvey
good day
right and then it would cut to joe green
and the bz copter
live above the tanks talking about the
backup on the southeast expressway
i remember thinking that's the coolest
[ __ ] job ever to be joe green in the
bz copter um
concord experience all right this is
gonna be uh this is gonna be some some
questions from the uh listeners oh look
at this billy in the sky with diamonds
uh long time listener first time writer
you know bill when i was younger
not even 20 i knew a man named bj that
flew on the concord
oh wow this is i was talking about i
always wanted to fly
from you know jfk in new york to paris
on the concord
you know just feeling like roger moore
uh
the [ __ ] white tuxedo you can't be
classy like sean conner you got to be a
little loud i like roger roger moore was
a little louder
a little more cheeky as they say over
there [ __ ] england uh i knew a man
named bj that flew on the concord he was
an insurance salesman who cut his teeth
as a b-42 bomber crewman
during world war ii when he was my age
holy [ __ ]
i mean if that's not the skit one of the
scariest [ __ ] jobs ever he was also
dressed to the nines and was very
amiable a good soul
i wish i had that i wish i was a classy
older guy
you know one of those people that could
wear a sport coat and a pocket square
and not look like he's trying too hard
you know unfortunately most people from
my generation at least the the people
that i hang out with
yeah they all dress like it's the first
day of school in eighth grade
you know what i mean
they got like a hoodie they got a you
know
brand new yankee hat a red sox hatha you
got to have the official one right
and then you got a pair like you know
clean basketball sneakers
and you can't tell them
that they don't look good
all right
all of these guys that i know furzi
giannis i mean they they like
giannis pop like when they when they get
a new pair of sneakers one of my
favorite things
because i love those guys you know when
you love people you want to see him
happy there's no nothing better
than seeing paul versi
get a new [ __ ] like yankee fitted
and a new pair of [ __ ] sneakers i'm
telling you
when paul versi gets that on he's
suddenly five eight and a half
[Laughter]
anyway he gained a passion for aviation
from his time going back to the thing
here
in the service i i commend that guy if i
was in a plane and people were [ __ ]
shooting at me and all my friends you
know weren't coming back and everything
i would think you know some i think i'm
going to stay on the ground
um anyway and was fascinated by the
progression of that technology he got to
fly in the concord a few times because
he was rich and he loved telling me
about it the luxury the feeling of
takeoff and the power of the engines
those were rolls-royce engines i believe
uh it truly must have seemed like an
alien technology to him my mother told
me stories about my grandfather who was
a radio operator for the merchant
marines during the war and his
excitement over the new portable
transistor radios it must have been an
incredible time to be alive uh he gave
me a few vhs tapes on planes and the
concord itself it still sits on my shelf
as a memento
it's truly it truly was an amazing plane
well first of all i gotta tell you
something man uh that guy is the old man
that i want to be
dressed to the nines still doing cool
[ __ ]
and then like
telling stories to younger people that
makes them want to learn about stuff and
then become a cool old guy
um
that's a big like
thing for me
oh speaking of which you know what i
didn't tell you guys i went to the
whiskey
last thursday night
and for the first time since 1988 i saw
def leppard
live but the first time i saw him was in
reynolds coliseum
in north carolina i had like third row
and i was standing between
rick savage
and the late great steve clark
right
is that his name i i don't know going
way back in the bank here
um
and they put on this amazing amazing
show
and um
that was the hysteria tour so i had not
seen them in 34 years right
and
so they were having an album release
party i downloaded their new album you
should check it out man it's a [ __ ]
good album
and what i loved when they came out on
stage
was they all looked great
and they were all having a great time
and
i learned a lot just from watching that
you know what i mean like sometimes you
know i go out and i still go see those
bands you know from when i was a kid
and when you go out and the band's not
having fun anymore
it just becomes like really depressing
and it makes you feel i mean it makes me
feel about my own mortality and i start
thinking oh man you know these guys are
10 years older than me how much time did
they have left how much time do i have
left and you just feel awful but when
you go out and see a band like def
leppard it's the exact opposite
you don't think about your mortality
they like remind you to go out and live
you know because there's a lot of people
they they [ __ ] quit man they quit i
swear they quit early 20s 30s they just
quit it's like they're serving out a
[ __ ] sentence
waiting for some pension i don't know
what
but um
they came out
and they uh they opened with one of
their new songs
um and i really liked it
i forget the name of it they played two
new ones they played this other one
kicked that i really liked
and had this great chorus that seemed
like a really good can be a really good
sing-along when they do the uh for the
crowd when they do the uh
the baseball stadium tour
um
and they just went out and they killed
it they played a tight set and they did
uh
they did uh it was for sirius xm it was
like simultaneously cast or whatever and
what i loved was joe elliott
he's
singing better than he's ever sung
and he uh
he was really funny
so in between songs i remember when they
they played like
the last song
and he was just i can't do the english
accent so forgive me he was just like
right this is the part where we usually
walk off stage and hopefully you'd keep
clapping
so we come back for the encore but you
know it's
tiny little space here so why don't you
just act like we [ __ ] off and now
we're back
and just clap for us and we'll play
and everybody's like he's just really
cool
he had that uh
older englishman
like funny gentleman vibe man he just
really cool dude
and um
it was also great
you know just watching phil collin and
vivian campbell
shredding on guitar
and uh
i remember watching i was just like i
[ __ ] missed this
i remember that going to concerts just
watching those guys going up and down
the neck like [ __ ] wizards
and um
i was also watching that drummer
obviously in his left leg the whole time
was like dancing around back there
and i always knew like you know when he
first came back after his injury
that one of those that he was playing
the snare now rather than with his left
arm he was playing it with his left foot
but he had a bunch of pedals back there
and he was playing
the fills perfectly
that he played when he had two arms so i
was like how's he doing that because
especially one of the fills was like
like a flam with a kick like black
whatever going down the kit
and he played the flam perfectly
so i'm like because he also had a snare
traditionally between his legs and i'm
like is he playing a flam between his
right hand and his left leg
that's incredible
and i actually looked at his setup
online his drum tech put it up and i
think he has
like right in the middle is his snare
drum if he moves his foot to the left i
think that's a bass drum
so it's like bass drum snare drum and
then the other pedal is a floor tom and
then on his his bass drum foot he has
the bass drum and then to the right he
has another floor tom
and i think he plays like doubles with
his right hand doubles with his kicks
when he's doing like with his kick foot
when he's doing like
16th notes down the top it's fascinating
and the sound sources change
so he's kind of like a guitar player
where he has to like you know
the drums it's easy like snare drum kick
it's always there with guitar players
it's like all right this is a g but
where on the neck am i playing the g
it's almost like that but um
i gotta say you know for all the troops
out there you know you're coming back if
you have injuries and that type of stuff
i really suggest
checking out his
setup
um
and hearing how amazing that he plays
with three limbs and all of that or
anybody who sustained an injury i that's
what my first thought was like man this
guy should go to walter reed
and inspire
people speaking of memorial day
on um
that you know it's not over like there's
still all this fun that you can have and
it's really like it kind of reminded me
of like uh you know self-taught guitar
players out there that play like a uh
they're left-handed and they just picked
up a right-handed guitar strung
right-handed and they just made it work
and they come up with their own shapes
to make the chords and stuff like that
it's already like he reinvented the drum
kit but he's been playing like that for
like i don't know 35 years or so
so he's a master at it and
he [ __ ] rips what i'm saying is is
when motley crue def leppard poison and
uh
joan jett all go out this summer you
should definitely check out that tour
because uh you know
these guys have like
i don't know how many decades of
musicianship under their belt and
they're gonna [ __ ] kill it so sorry
that was a big sidetrack there but i had
to bring it up
um here we go leave animals the [ __ ]
alone
dear billy the wise
in response to your statement leave
animals the [ __ ] alone i would like to
share this article with you please focus
your anger towards these nerds who keep
[ __ ] with the planet the next time
there's a pandemic
from all their work in their [ __ ] ass
lab p.s i love science but come on
uh gene editing turns fluffy hamsters
into aggressive rage monsters
okay i'm in this is like one of those
creature double features this sounds
like one of the movies
gene editing experimenting turns fluffy
hamsters into aggressive
mutant rage animal monsters
oh my god well maybe they can finally
beat the [ __ ] out of this i mean they're
based those things exist to be like
appetizers like hamsters are the sliders
of the food chain
can i get you started with something a
mouse a hamster
a team of scientists in the u.s have
accidentally created overly aggressive
mutant hamsters following a gene editing
experiment and they should destroy all
of them but they won't using the
controversial cr crispr crispr
technology researchers at northwest
western university shout out to the big
ten
we're examining a hormone called
vasopressin and it's receptor
avrala
no avpro 1a they opted to try and remove
the ladder from a group of syrian
hamsters
syrian hamsters oh geez uh it always
goes back to the middle east doesn't it
uh with the exception
uh with the expectation it would
increase bonding and cooperation between
the lovable little critters why don't
you leave them the [ __ ] alone
that's because avpr 1a is understood to
regulate things like teamwork and
friendship as well as dominance and
bonding this is what they're trying to
do they're trying to make us a bunch of
[ __ ] lackeys
their expectation proved to be wrong
very wrong we were all really surprised
at the results we were anticipated that
if we illuminated vasopressin activity
we would reduce both aggression and
social communication but the opposite
happened the academics found the
adorable bundles of fluff turned into
mutant rage monsters
um
all they have is videos dude this looks
like a ufc fight
you know they're already taking it to
the [ __ ] ground if you want to read
this it's on metro.co.uk
of course it's over in the uk and then i
got to [ __ ] tell us what we're doing
over here right
um
gene edit gene editing turns fluffy
hamsters into aggressive rage monsters
check that out
um
insane anyway something badass i own
that i am unworthy of
dear billy uterine lining
i don't even know what that means
but that is amazing i'm sure it's
insulting and i accept it if it's going
to be that funny
uh billy uterine lining
i'm missing the the if if billy uterine
it sounds like something i never took a
[ __ ] health class so i don't know
anything
about the vagina other than it [ __ ]
dominates my life um i have a badass
authentic expensive cowboy hat that i
don't deserve
i'm from philly in boston but i'm an
irish catholic alcoholic [ __ ]
ah dude i got a big place in my heart
for you i release who is a black hole of
irritability i bought the hat for a
halloween costume and couldn't go cheap
because you know life is a competition
and everyone is out to get me
uh i even drove 90 minutes to an
authentic western supply store the last
time i went to texas everyone was so
impossibly nice and well-mannered my
heart warmed until i grew depressed at
how much liquid
[ __ ] runs through my veins
in texas a teenager once went well out
of his way to hold the door for me and i
froze i was so confused i assumed he he
wanted me to cast him
in something
follow him on instagram or blow him
oh you in the business here
cast him
blowing people i mean that's how you
make it in hollywood
um it'll be all in the book someday um
he didn't want any of that just wanted
to be thoughtful of a stranger like a
[ __ ] psychopath
uh someday i'm gonna go to a ranch for a
month ride horses
and [ __ ] some goats or maybe my cousins
or maybe the goat's cousin in order to
earn this boss cowboy hat yeah dude you
got the [ __ ] irish anger big time the
fact you couldn't just say i'm gonna go
to a ranch because it spoke to me and
brought peace to my heart you got to
bring like bestiality into it just so
you could you know so nobody goes oh do
you like to ride a horsey you [ __ ]
queer
all that homophobic [ __ ] um
listen just because you were born
and lived in boston
in philly doesn't mean there's you know
all of us connect to nature there's
nothing wrong
you know
i i go out there in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere and you know
it there's something great about it it's
the same thing
like smoking a cigar by yourself or
having a cup of coffee you know
without a loud group of people chatting
um i had a nice cup of coffee by myself
this morning
you know
and um
there's a couple lesbians next to me but
they were hot so it didn't bother me you
know what i'm saying kid sorry i'm going
back to boston
um
actually we're really good-looking i'm
not gonna lie to you
and one of them was going like you know
james dean
and the other one was the hottie and i
was just looking at him you know in
hollywood mode going like if that was
like a buddy comedy and they stole a car
like i'm in i'm watching that movie um
home remedies everybody hey billy
shivers oh i missed that paul version
came up with that billy shiv is there
i grew up in the 70s and 80s like you
you weren't very uh well off and lived
in an old farmhouse from the 1800s oh we
weren't uh any time you got sick or hurt
it was two things vick's vapor rub oh
absolutely and those goddamn cherry
soucrets
that came in at ten yeah that's what you
did you got the flu vicks all over your
[ __ ] body that was all your chest
you know unless your uncle came over and
he did a little too much thorough job um
and we didn't uh have air conditioning
in this old house
so you just went to bed smelling like
peppermint patties [ __ ] headaches
soucrets stuffy nose vicks and secrets
broken arm cherry [ __ ] secrets yeah
that's the truth
um
broken arm they put it in a sling
then you got a frozen shoulder and you
had a crooked forearm for the rest of
your life anyways hiccups they suck a
home remedy my grandmother would try
was to take a straw put it in your mouth
sideways and bite down on it
like you were getting ready for a civil
war amputation
uh then you take little sips of whatever
you want to drink while the straw is in
your mouth probably to just keep your
mind busy so you're not thinking about
the hiccups but it works maybe that's
what it is saw you in phoenix love the
podcast and go stuff a dry umbrella up
your ass and open it jesus christ
good luck with the forthcoming movie how
about that for a visual
um
all right oh somebody's looking for
advice hang on a second hang on a second
i gotta use uh the one and only time i
get to not the one and only time man i
got a little windows open here hey i got
a friend of mine he likes to open
windows
closing windows
i wish i knew how to just make it all go
away i know there's a shortcut here we
go okay here we go
hey
that's me
all right it's advice time everybody
advice for a british guy
hey
oh [ __ ]
little deft leopard high and dry
come on you can tell me you like a dj
better than that i'm sure you do um i
don't uh hey billy back blast uh i'm a
22 year old guy living in the uk
i never been to the states and i've
always wanted to move there
why don't you just visit first
see if you like it he goes i met a 26
year old lady
on xbox i know xbox hear me out hear me
out so i randomly joined a group of
americans playing red dead re redemption
part two
um doozy
um and she joined just after we click
pretty much instantly we can laugh about
pretty much anything and we have tons in
common we both love working out the same
tv shows and movies etc from the first
day we started messaging each other
through xbox a lot we messaged on there
every day for a month and then started
talking on facebook we've grown really
close and there's definitely interest
from both sides we talk every day
messages and phone calls oh you're onto
phone calls i'm head over heels for this
chick and the distance is obviously an
issue i want to tell her exactly how i
feel but i'm worried because it's going
to take at least a year or maybe two
to be in a position to move i know it's
dumb bill but help a british brother out
a british [ __ ]
uh she's one of a one of a kind and no
one i've ever met is even half the
person she is
why are you telling me this you should
tell it to her i'm visiting her home
state november there you go and she's
made comments about how i should come
and walk her dog while she works and
help around the apartment how do i
approach the situations i'll tell you
how you do it
you keep being cool you keep talking to
her
don't [ __ ] spill your guts about
being in love with her or whatever you
think it is until you you meet her and
you really see that this is true
who knows she might have a goofy walk
and it might [ __ ] with your emotions and
then all of a sudden you said you love
what love her then you gotta [ __ ]
break up with her
you know take a long flight home i would
i would play you know whatever you're
doing i would keep doing he said how do
i approach the situation i've already
been holding it back for months and life
is short what the [ __ ] do i do p.s i
love efforts for family and all your
shows i hope you come to i hope to come
to one of your shows sometime thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself
um
i don't know usually i'm one to just say
tell her what you're thinking but you
know there's a little bit of distance
here
um
i don't know i i do whatever you're
doing seems to be working i would just
keep doing that
and uh
you know
throw some stuff out there
just say you know i really look forward
to talking to you every day and then she
mean i really look forward to talking to
you too and you got to read that
you know was she just being nice is
should we playing the repeat game i
think about you a lot i think about you
too
it's like okay
can you come up with some original nice
[ __ ] to say to me instead of just are
you just like
being pleasant i don't know you got to
be honest with you man i've been out of
the game a long time
all right
i got ice on both knees here you're
talking a really old guy here so i would
just say keep doing what you're doing
and uh
i wouldn't you know because there's
distance there it could get a little
weird if you push it too hard
it seems like she wants to get to know
you better
with you know walking the dog and you're
coming to see her she obviously likes
you if she just like likes you
you know she doesn't want you to go walk
her dog you know what i mean so i think
the signals are there
but because of the distance i don't know
i i think you just keep like
you know
just be [ __ ] cool make her laugh
keep staying in touch tell her that
you're excited to see her i would let
the big emotions happen
face to face
you know what i mean
and uh you know if you end up uh kissing
or whatever then i think that's a time
to go
a little bigger and
tell her what you're telling me i think
it's a little i think it's a little
weird via text
or via headset while playing red dead
redemption
two
going you know i think i might be
falling in love with you oh watch out
for that cop behind the door you know i
wouldn't be doing it while you're
playing a video game
um other than that i don't know how love
works in 2022. all right
but i'm rooting for you
okay
both in the video game and in life all
right that's it everybody
uh thanks for listening go [ __ ]
yourselves enjoy your memorial day which
it's already half over or three quarters
over um and don't get any arguments
today all right have some burgers have
some hot dogs you know
say a prayer for the troops all the
troops around the world anybody who has
to fight in a [ __ ] war
you know what i mean
you got to do that because at the end of
the day if you're just like me and you
just play drums
and you get excited about a double shot
of espresso you know
you're not a hero
i don't care what they call you
you're not all right so tip your cap to
the people that deserve it
all right chew your [ __ ] food